good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 139 object class
Keter special containment procedures SCP
139 is to be kept in a room at least 6
meters at its smallest dimension
suspended at least 2 meters from the
nearest inside surface of the room no
one is to enter this room under any
circumstance the room is never to be
left without at least two armed guards
at any moment description the object
appears on the surface to be a poorly
preserved skull of a hominid it is
missing the lower jaw bone also of note
is the extreme where especially to the
eye sockets photography of the skull has
been analyzed by leading anthropologists
and all agree that the specimen is too
badly damaged to be identified with
complete accuracy and then it is most
definitely hominid while some believe it
is a standard Neanderthal skull others
are convinced that the white cavities
are the result of wear and that the
original size was much smaller more like
that of a modern human this is because
the size of the nasal and ocular
cavities was the main feature leading
some to identify the skull as
Neanderthal however all were confounded
by the ridge at the top of the skull
this feature is most commonly associated
with prehistoric herbivorous species of
hominids one of our own anthropologists
has proposed the theory that the ridge
is the sign of a powerfully jawed animal
such ridges generally act as anchors for
jaw muscles such as in Paranthropus
boisei eye these animals used their
heavy jaw muscles for chewing plants but
it is also feasible that with sharp
teeth they could easily be used for
the following was translated by doctor
from Ori a document TTD l67 when
discovered the skull was located in a
small town just south of the throne of
Jamshed talked a gem shed or throne of
Jamshed has been determined to be a
modern farside name for Persepolis the
skull was first recorded by Douglas
Winthrop an Englishman an employee of
anglo-iranian oil
70s roughly 1950s on the Gregorian
calendar Winthrop was an amateur
anthropologist seeking fame and glory
and came upon the town hoping to find a
living missing link he believed that the
residents of the town may be living
Leander Thals though this hypothesis was
quickly abandoned upon inspection of the
townspeople
he did uncover the skull when discovered
the skull was being held in an iron and
copper cage suspended 50 feet 15.2 4
metres in the air from a cliff using
hemp rope the rope was tied to a hook
drilled into the side of the cliff
implying an intention never to bring it
back down a pulley was present however
it was attached to a wall erected on the
edge of the cliff the pulley was used to
lower food and water down towards the
skull the people refer to the skull as
the skull of the white dip in ancient
lore the white give is a demon and the
spawn of a rhymin who was the sum of all
evil the white divin legend is a being
of great and mystic power defeated by
Rostow rostam is a legendary hero of
persia reportedly the div was slain in
the northern hills of what is now
azerbaijan according to the townspeople
the skull had been brought to their town
by a madman who had slain many men
before they discovered the power of the
skull and it was contained and put in
its current position
Winthrop was soon overcome with madness
himself slaughtering seven of his
friends after his return to England he
was also charged and convicted of
sodomizing several male and female
animals among them several chickens a
male and female dog and three Bulls he
did not however managed to bring the
skull back as it was confiscated by the
University of Shiraz under the Shahs
authority after the confiscation however
no new research became of it the
artifacts surfaced next in the Yukon 90
kilometers from the Alaskan border the
entire community of the caribou crossing
what is known today as car cross Yukon
was found brutally murdered by multiple
stab wounds semen was found inside the
wounds and that is assumed the assailant
ejaculated into the incisions the
corpses were found stacked in a large
pile in the centre of the chapel on top
of the pile of corpses was the skull the
artifact has since been in our custody
its properties are unknown what has
driven such superstition in its wake is
unknown what has brought it to the scene
of intense carnage is unknown the safety
precautions currently taken are done so
simply because they have thus far proven
effective why is not no no research is
planned
working for the foundation it's not all
fun and games is it anyway thank you all
for listening if indeed you still are
and you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Muslim Mookie slump god Justin day
John reporter captain Gorge fluffy dread
my archive curator neck tie verbal Kody
tench cheese whip depths McGee and
oblong dish boy if you would like a
special Thank You the end of each of my
videos and some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]